الستار اليوم على جريمه شغله الراي العام
من ثلاث سنوات او اكثر شوي المحكمه اليوم
اصدرت قرارها بمنع محاكمه الدكتور فادي
الهاشم زوج الفنانه نانسي عجرم بتهمه
القتل لمحمد الموسى الشاب السوري اللي
بحسبه التحقيقات اقتحم منزل الثنائي بدافع
السرقه واطلق عليه فادي 8 و18 رصاصه القصه
صارت في 5 يناير 2019 وبدات الروايات من
وقتها الروايه الاولى والرسميه للان محمد
الموسى كان داخل يسرق ولما انتبه عليه
الدكتور فادي اطلق عليه النار ومن اول يوم
فادي مصر انه الموضوع كان دفاع عن النفس
لكن تحليلات للمشهد والفيديوهات والصور
وتفاصيل كثيره بدات تطلع وتقول كلام ثاني
فسمعنا كلام عن علاقه بتربط بين الاثنين
من قبل وتساؤلات انه ليه 18 طلقه وعلامات
استفهام عن مكان وجود الجثه وانه ما تتفق
مع روايه الدفاع عن النفس وكلام ثاني كثير
ولكن الهيئه اليوم اصدرت قرارها سكتت
الكلام خلاص واصدرت حكم القانون ومنعت
محاكمه فادي الهاشم وقالت انه في مبرر
للفعل اخرجوا من نطاق التجريم وانه المدعى
عليه كان في حاله دفاع عن النفس خاصه مع
الوضع النفسي اللي كان فيه وجود القتيل في
مكان قريب جدا من غرفه بناته فضلا عن لبسه
اسود في اسود والظلام اللي كان في الغرفه
وقتها
الاعلام كله جالس بيتناول الموضوع على انه
براءه دكتور فادي الهاشم لكن الموضوع
قانونيا مو براءه من القضاء منع المحاكمه
اصلا خليني اشرح لكم بس الموضوع مثل ما
يعني نحن من محاميين ومختصين بالقانون في
لبنان الوثيقه المنتشره للحكم ومثل مو
شايفين ما فيها كلمه براءه لانه ببساطه
صادره عن الهيئه الاتهاميه اللي ما لها
صلاحيه انه تحكم بالبراءه هذا غير انه
القضيه ما وصلت اصلا لمحكمه الجنايات
ليبدا التقاضي فيها الهيئه الاتهاميه هذه
اللي المفروض توجه التهمه للمتهم ومن
بعدها تروح للقضيه من محكمه الجنايات وبعد
ما بحثت في القضيه لقيت انه صحيح في جرم
قتل وقع لكن في مبرر بيخليه فعل مشروع ولا
يستدعي المحاكمه وبيمنعها وهذا اللي صار
في هذه القضيه مبرر الدكتور فادي كان
الدفاع عن النفس والهيئه الاتهاميه مبرر
يستوجب منع محاكمته من الاساس